hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular game that was played in the
Charlotte fall Invitational Tournament
where a young International Masters were
invited to try and get their Grandmaster
norms and it's a game between abhimanyu
Mishra and Hans moken Neiman now I have
not seen this game prior to yesterday
I've seen it in a video by Joshua
Iglesias if you haven't seen her video
do check it out I will put a link to it
in the description below she made a very
nice compilation of all of the games
that Hans Neiman play not all of them
but the the more incriminating ones and
what I found interesting is that she
titled the video the most incriminating
evidence against Hans Neiman now English
is only my second language so I was very
much interested what is the well
basically what's the difference between
evidence and proof and well if you if
you check the dictionary really quickly
you will get this uh let me just check
I've uh I have it somewhere yeah it will
have this basically so this is what I I
found what is the difference between
evidence and proof so basically what it
says sorry it takes a bit longer to set
it up what is the difference between
evidence and proof and it says that
proof is the final verdict that removes
all doubts whereas evidence only leads
one in the direction of a fact or
statement now it's a very interesting
definition because okay you have proof
you have proofed I mean you have the The
Smoking Gun but if you have evidence it
leads one into a Direction but it could
also lead one into a wrong direction so
just something to keep in mind so
I mean it's a it's a very nice video and
I I really enjoyed it but it does not
really prove anything so it's very easy
to jump on the bandwagon and you know
become part of a part of a Witch Hunt
but what I'm interested in is only the
truth and what actually happened now
well this is not something that we will
probably find out anytime soon it's
probably gonna take a while I did while
watching her video run into this
spectacular game so abhimanyu Mishra the
youngest Grand Master ever don't be
fooled by his young appearance he's an
incredible Beast he became a grand
master at this game was played he was 11
when he was played he became a grand
master before Bobby Fischer before
Magnus Crossing and of course before uh
the person who held the record for the
youngest Grandmaster at the time Sergey
kariakin and the the game is truly
remarkable it really remind uh resembles
something
you would see in a game of a very very
strong engine uh much like for example
Alpha zero if you remember that game
we're Alpha zero uh trapped uh the the
queen uh his Queen on purpose and then I
mean there was just nothing to do for
stockfish now let's check out the game
enjoy it I do feel like this is the best
game I've seen Hans play uh and then we
are going discuss uh what what they
played why they played it and what is
the uh well uh what is the the strength
of the moves they have played if you ask
our good friend the engine so let's
check it out Mishra has the white pieces
and he opens with Ponte E4 we have Pawn
to E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now
Bishop the C4 Mishra goes for the
Italian game Knight to F6 we have the
two knights defense by Hans and now D3
we have H6 so nothing new here C3 D6 and
now uh Mishra castles and here we have
G5 by Hans G6 is a bit more popular G5 I
feel um is more appealing to younger
player players might beat the D2 and now
usually Bishop to G7 is played here but
Hans goes for the immediate G4 and it's
a very very
interesting game that arises now there
is one game where Knights the H4 was
played and it is the absolute correct
move that should be played uh if you ask
our good friend the engine here at night
the E1 by Mishra only uh maybe the
engine prefers Knight the H for slightly
better or slightly more than Knights the
E1 but okay it is now as of move 8 that
we have a completely new game so hunt
continues to push Pawn to H5 with F4 by
Mishra and now e captures an F4 you
could also consider G captures on F3 but
after Queen captures anyone who ever
played the king's Gambit knows that this
is very good for white so after F4 we
have e captures on F4 and now Rook
captures on F4 we have Bishop to H6 by
Mishra attacking the rook and just Rook
backed a story by Hans and Rook to F1 by
Mishra uh we have Queen to E7 and now
Knight to B3 preparing to bring the
knights to D4 we have Knight the E5 now
attacking the bishop and here uh abimanu
plays Bishop captures on H6 of course he
wants to get rid of of this bishop
controlling this nice diagonal Rook
captures and now plays Knight to D2 now
this is a very important move for how
this game will continue I will show
after the game why also Knights the D4
can be played but okay Knights the D2
defending the bishop here you don't want
your Pawn structure to get messed up and
now Hans plays Bishop to D7 and okay he
wants the castle Queen side with Bishop
to B3 uh I'll be my new now doesn't
allow the bishop to be captured and pawn
to G3 this allows Abby to play H3 and
not allow opening of the king side but
also this Pawn is now incredibly strong
uh regarding H2 and F2 we have Knight
Knight F to G4 seems like okay you're
maybe giving up a knight but not really
if if you actually accepted this then
there's no defending this position with
black I mean there's so many things to
worry about even to give you an example
if a silly movies played Just Rook H1
check and it's game over the King has to
capture Queen checks King here and queen
to H2 will be Checkmate so the Knight is
there to stay so here we have Queen to
E2 developing the queen also defending
the D3 Pawn so the Knight can move and
now Knight the H2 attacking the rook and
that there really is no good Square for
this Rook we have Queen to E3 attacking
this Rook so offering a rook trade but
Hans just moves The Rook back Rook to H7
it is the absolute best move as the F7
Pawn of course has to be protected so
here we have Rook to F4
also to be considered is Rook to F5 as
The Rook really does not have any
squares as you'll see even even F4 is
not safe for The Rook so Rook to F4 H4
by Hans now guarding the G3 pawn and now
Pawn to D4 chasing away the Knight
Knight the G6 and now the Rook must uh
be captured as there are no squares so
here Knights the D3 by Mishra and now uh
Hans just castles Queen side there's no
point in rushing The Rook capture
there's no square for The Rook so here
Rook the E1 we have Rook to E8 and now
Pawn to E5 and now okay the pawn The
Rook must be captured because abhimanyu
will play Rook D4 and then black will be
in trouble so here Hans captures the
Knight captures on F4 Knight captures on
F4 and now Pawn to C6 taking away the D5
Square from abhimanyu's pieces Knight
the C4 now as the D6 square has been
weakened so of course he wants to attack
that and now Pawn to D5 now inviting the
Knight to D6 but this is exactly what
Hans want and this is also one of the
reasons I really thoroughly enjoyed this
game so Knights the D6 and now Hans
plays the only move for black that uh
keeps Advantage uh Queen characters on
D6 trading Queens here he captures on D6
Rook captures on E3 Rook captures an E3
and now just to Rook to H6 seemingly
going after the D6 Pawn because why not
uh and here there's a really no good
move for white to play uh Mishra plays
the absolute best move but it's still
not enough he plays Knight to E2 his
idea is of course that he wants the
captain g3h captures Rook captures and
then the Knight will be undefended he
will win back his piece but also grab
the two pawns but there is a problem
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to find what the Hans played here as
it's uh truly an incredible revelation
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
incredible brilliancy and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is a rook the E6 not capturing the pawn
because if you capture the pawn like we
said then just Knight captures and G3 H
captors Rook captures and then the
Knight will fall as well and there's
really no good way to play this for
example Rook F6 you're gonna capture the
knight any fruit F2 going after the beat
you upon you just start marching the the
H Pawn of the Border you can even
threaten the F Pawn and if Bishop
defends it now you play H4 and black is
never in time to grab the pawn if black
grabs the pawn H5 H6 and at some point
black will have to give up the bishop
for for the pawn so after Knight E2
hunts played the Incredible Rook to E6
and now you realize the horror of
abhimanyu's position uh the the Rooks
must be traded of course the the there
is no way to defend the rook and now
after Rook captures an E6 and Bishop
captures on E6 you you realize what is
actually happening here it's not hans's
Knight that's strapped on H2 it's
actually a bimanus king that is trapped
on G1 so while Hans will play some part
of the game without the Knight I'll be
Manu will play pretty much the rest of
the game without a king as the pawn
covers F2 the Knight covers F1 the king
cannot enter the end game and what is
the most important and strongest piece
of the end game of course it is the
marching King so here Avi plays Bishop
to C2 we have King to D7 now Hans starts
marching his King into the game Knight
to F4 King captures on D6 we have Pawn
to B4 and pawn to B5 we have Pawn to A4
and just B captors and A4 Bishop
captures and now Bishop to F5
uh the idea is that at some point of
course uh black I'll be mine will have
to play something the bishop will come
to uh to D3 guard the F1 square and then
the Knight will be introduced back into
the game the light Square Bishop can do
this from any diagonal you could also
put it on this diagonal it's important
to keep an eye on the F1 Square so here
Bishop to B3 uh we have Bishop to E6 and
now Bishop to A4 abimanu repeats the
position uh but Hans now shows that
there is a way to exploit the diagonal
Bishop to C8 with Bishop to D1 uh of
course hoping for Bishop to E2 but now
just Bishop to A6 and now there is no
good way to do it and uh of course
abhimanyu wants to stop night at night
F1 so he plays Bishop to E2 and offers a
trade of Bishops a more resilient way to
play this e but even with that it's hard
to say if it would be enough it's Bishop
H5 going after the pawn allowing Knights
to F1 and then after Bishop captures on
F7 King E7 and after Bishop H5 Knight
the E3 so whether it's possible to to
survive this with white it's hard to say
because Bishop to F1 is coming you're
going to start gobbling up these pawns
or the Knight will have to remain here
it's a very very uh hard hard position
to even find the move for white of
course if you try to go for a pawn just
King F6 and now of course the pawn
cannot be captured because King G5
attacks the Knight and the bishop so
it's an incredibly difficult position
for white so well maybe it's possible to
save it it's it's hard to say I'll be
mine who plays Bishop to A2 he offers a
trade of Bishops Bishop captures I need
to Knight captures on E2 and now just
King to E6 you could also get the king
into the game via the queen side also
possibly is to just get the king to C4
Knight to C1 now uh sorry Knights the C1
now uh King to F5 and now Knight the B3
we have King the E4 and not Knight the
A5 going after C6 and A7 but Hans plays
it uh perfectly of course not King D3
but rather Pawn to F5 this is the
forcing line F4 F3 F2 white will have to
play captures at some point so Knight
captures and C6 we have F4 by Hans B5
now preparing to capture and the score
to the the B Pawn of the board but now
Pawn to F3 and you cannot allow F2 check
if you allow F2 checking H1 F1 will be
Checkmate so G captures an F3 Knight
captures with check King F1 and now the
only winning move Knight to G5 going
after the H3 pawn and of course King G2
is impossible if you play King to G2
then look at this Knight the E6 going
after this check and even after Knight
captures an A7 Knight F4 checking the G1
King F3 for example B6 G2 B7 there's
Knights the E2 check and of course now
you get checkmated H2 and G1 Queen is
checkmate so after Knight G5 Knight the
E5 by abhimanyu this is again the
absolute best way to try and defend
Knight characters on H3 now we have
Knights the G6 going after the pawn but
just the G2 check beautifully played by
Hans uh uh forcing the game into into a
king and pawn end game the knights are
now coming off the board that you have
to capture otherwise G1 is Queen so King
captures Knight to F4 check forcing a
trade of knights Knight Knight captures
King captures and look at this equal
material but Hans is completely winning
here because the past the past H Pawn is
too strong of course Mishra has to deal
with it so King H3 and now Han simply
marches his King to the other side of
the board to gobble up all of the pawns
King to E4 King captures an H for King
D3 King the G4 King captures and C3 King
to F5 King captors on D4 King to E6 and
now King the C5 and he was in this
position unmoon 56 that abhimanyu Mishra
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once you make a
move let's any move just King captures
on B5 and after King captures you just
escort the a pawn of the board if the
white king tries to stop it you just
counter the the white king you you
always create opposition King be three
King D2 King B2 and now the pawn is
safely escorted while the white king is
completely
blocked away from ever reaching that
pawn
so after King to C5 abhimanyu resigned
the game and uh yeah this is this is one
truly spectacular game well I mean uh
just trapping your own Knight on
trapping your own Knight on H2 like this
is is such a such a positional
Masterpiece I mean and already happening
on move 17 uh of course you you realize
that you will uh probably win that Rook
but still uh once uh once this Rook uh
runs away the Knight is trapped there
basically uh Hans is playing without a
piece but uh I'll be mine is playing
without a piece but then Hans just
showed uh that it's actually white who
is playing without a king after he
played this beautiful Rook the E6 uh for
single Rook trade but even if Bobby
Manuel doesn't play this night they eat
you move there there's no good uh move
for you to play if you allow Rook to F6
then the Knight is stuck there for the
rest of the game because of the Rook to
F1 Checkmate threat so you you cannot
allow this I mean you absolutely have to
play Knights day too
[Music]
to oppose this because then of course an
idea like uh Rook to F6 is met by just
Knight captures and G3 that's the whole
point the age captures three captures
and the the Knight gets taken off the
board so while it loses the game abimanu
in fact played the the absolute best
move so while it's interesting uh of
course you guys are now uh very much
interested in how many of uh hans's
moves were top engine moves and how many
of them were second the engine uh second
top engine moves uh pretty much all of
them were top engine moves and the top
second engine moves but guess what so
are so are abima news so basically all
of them I mean the the two of them play
the perfect game it was only a slight
imprecision by by abhimanyu that allowed
this masterpiece to happen from Hansen
it's very hard to tell to really pin it
down I I mentioned this Knight to D2
maneuver that Mishra played trying to
guard this bishop and I said it maybe
better was Knight to D4 point being that
the you can never ruin white structure
because if Knight captures just Queen
tape or check wins back the night so
it's perfectly fine for white so well
it's a knight to the D4 and then after
after G3 you will play late night the E
Knight to F3 and after G captures on H2
King to H1 and it's a very very nice
position for white white has a very good
game a lot of pressure along the f file
the Knight can come to F5 at any point
so the Queenie for check always a
resource so it's a it's a very nice
position and it's one that could have
happened and the only other basically
imprecision that
bimanu played was maybe this offer of a
bishop maybe bishop to H5 is stronger
but still it's hard to say if you could
if you could handle this game so while
both well yes uh uh Hans played many
many top engine moves and many many top
second engine moves and third engine
moves uh so did ABI Manu I mean they
played literally the the the the perfect
game uh only abhimanyu made a slight
imprecision in uh in maybe a move or two
and Hans took advantage of that um just
beautifully
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it really wonderfully
played I mean uh this is this is why I
love chess I mean games like these where
where you voluntarily trap a knife for
like 20 moves and then just show that uh
that the Knight was never really trapped
it was in fact the white king that was
trapped I mean truly a a remarkable
maneuver uh so yeah if you guys still
haven't to do watch Yorkshire Iglesias
video uh it's already been watched by by
a lot of people has like over 300 000
views but do check it out do watch it
and let me know what you think about it
is the data truly that incriminating or
is it maybe still open to interpretation
I'm very interested in in what you guys
think uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it I I immensely
enjoyed it so I mean hopefully we have
many more games like like these in the
future I would like to thank uh anshuman
Shukla Henry's pragons and Mr Robert de
crayon Sarah medrata and Michael Evans
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day